[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK FELKER: Hey, I'm
Nick Felker, and today--
hold on, give me a second.
OK Google, turn on
the studio lights.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK,
turning the studio lights on.
NICK FELKER: Hey,
I'm Nick Felker,
and today I'm going to
talk to you about how
to make your Smart Home devices
work with the Google Assistant
without building a
conversational interface.
Right now that Google
Assistant works
with more than
1,500 smart devices
from over 200 popular brands.
I'll show you just how
easy it is for your devices
to be part of this ecosystem.
Hey Google, what's the weather
going to be like today?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Today
in Mountain View it
will be a high of 101 degrees.
NICK FELKER: Wow,
that's really hot.
I should find a way to cool off.
So imagine you have
a company selling
internet-connected fans, and you
want your users to control them
from the Google
Assistant, whether using
a voice-activated
speaker like Google
Home, their phone, an
Android TV, or any other
supported surface.
With the Actions on
Google Smart Home API,
you can integrate your existing
cloud-connected Smart Home
devices with the
Google Assistant.
In this example, our smart
fan has plastic fan blades
and a motor connected
to a developer board.
This device listens to
messages from our server
to turn on and off.
You can use any cloud service
and device operating system
that you want.
The choice is yours.
So let's get started with making
our fan work with the Google
Assistant.
You will need to connect
your web server to the Google
Assistant.
Your web hook will be called
when the user gives a command,
and your server will have
to process the request
and complete the user's query.
You can link this web hook
to a project in the Actions
on Google console.
Just select the option
to build for a Smart Home
and provide the URL
for your web hook.
In order to make sure that
each user is only controlling
their own fan, you will need
to set up OAuth credentials
so the Google Assistant
can communicate securely
to your server.
Smart home devices connect to
the HomeGraph, a database which
stores and provides contextual
information about the user's
home and the devices inside.
For example, HomeGraph
can store the concept
of a living room which contains
multiple types of devices
from different manufacturers.
Without having to deal with
parsing sentences yourself,
you can handle complex queries
like cool down living room
or make my living
room light brighter.
The Google Assistant
uses information
in order to execute
user requests based
on the appropriate context.
Your web hook communicates
with the Assistant servers,
receiving intents and responding
by taking action on devices,
or responding with information
about a user's devices.
For example, your
web hook will be
asked to provide a list of
user's connected devices
via a sync intent.
It can also be asked to
turn the fan on or off
with an execute intent.
Your client will have to
handle the actual management
of the state and execution.
If asked whether the fan
is on, a query intent
will ask your web
hook to provide
the current state of the fan.
When using Smart Home API,
you provide a list of traits
that your device can support.
For example, my fan
can turn on and off.
The Google Assistant handles
all the possible ways
you can say that.
You don't write
your own grammars
nor build a conversational app.
When you just say, "turn my
workshop fan on, please,"
the Google Assistant
processes your command.
The home graph understands that
you have a fan in your workshop
and that it can turn on and off.
Then the Google
Assistant will turn that
into a structured JSON payload
that it sends to your web
hook for processing.
After creating your
Smart Home integration,
you can use the Actions
on Google console
to view the usage and
health of your integration
from your users.
Now that web hook
is done, we can
open the Home Control Settings
in the Google Assistant.
I can link to the NIC app and
get back all of my devices.
Once the devices are
synced, I can control them.
OK Google, turn on
the workshop fan.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK,
turning the workshop fan on.
NICK FELKER: Ah,
this is much better.
I hope this video
helped explain how
to get started with integrated
your Smart Home devices
with the Google Assistant.
I think I'm
forgetting something.
OK Google, is my
smart fan still on?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Yes,
the workshop fan is on.
NICK FELKER: Visit
the documentation
to learn more about Smart
Home, and join our community
to discuss this with
other developers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]